the wife does address it to the husband
that he will shame her he'll be oh it's
your fault you can't be satisfied what I
say is depend how you approach it so if
your woman goes to you you don't perform
properly that's going to demasculate you
yes when it comes to the issue of ha
this
clip my name is Michael I came to Islam
4 years ago I had to learn how to pray
myself as I had no one to teach me how
to pray Salah when the Salah plus
project was launched I got my daughter a
free guided prayer map and I taught her
how to pray for the first time and
helped her memorize Surah fat there are
thousands of reverts like Michael around
the world who want to learn how to pray
Salah but there is no one to help them
what if I told you that by supporting
our charity you can help teach new
Muslims like Michael to not only learn
how to pray Salah but to teach their
kids and their family members to pray
Salah thanks to your donations a100 can
help teach 10 to 30 people learn how to
praise Sal and memor
for the first time ever click the link
in the description below and donate
now brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inshah so
I have not been on Twitter for the past
two and a half three years it's the best
decision I've made aldah it's just toxic
unnecessary arguments and you've got a
lot of people who are like I said before
like says they're like flies you know
they look at the mistake and the F they
just literally hunting for your mistake
amdah so what I did this brother and
sisters I totally came off it however
now there's been a video circulating
around uh about a specific clip that was
taken out when we discussing a specific
issue and um and I'm going to discuss
that and talk about that because there
was a question asked I'm going to be
talking about that I'm going to be
talking about the clip we're going to
watch it for oursel and my take on it
and um what I have to say on this matter
insh yeah because I think it's very very
important because at the end of the day
it is the honor of these sisters who
come to the show and the honor of these
brothers that are on the line um myself
I don't really care about what people
say about me like I I be honest I do not
care unless it's someone close to me
that I know who goes out like certain
individual I don't even want to mention
who's I believe the backstabber when
someone who can have my phone number he
can call me and advise me but he doesn't
and he goes and uh takes the side of an
enemy over his Muslim brother that's the
only thing that hurts me so before I get
into all of that I just want to mention
to you guys why I started the bit of
Truth show I didn't start the bit of Tri
show because I was bored and I thought
let me say you know I want to do some uh
free mixing whatever you want to call it
okay I started a bit of Tri show because
the biggest threat we have toiz divorce
rates people are getting divorced left
right center for the most pettiest
stupidest reasons me and my wife are
aware of okay we hear these story so I
thought to myself what can we do to do
this do to combat this because divorce
rates happening Left Right Center you
know so I thought to myself you know
what we can discuss these topics we need
to have the say of the sisters we don't
want to talk on their behalf neither
they should talk on our behalf we want
to hear them so we spoke to people of
knowledge before the show during the
show in and even after the show of
certain things that need to be improved
we're human beings the people that we
spoke to were High Senior Scholars High
Senior Scholars yeah that's why I'm
going to make it very clear yeah we
don't come with out of our own ideology
I wake up one day and give myself a f
and go I'm going to do this cuz I'm a
person of how I just I'm I'm into my
desires I just want I wake up and go how
can I disobey Allah his messenger today
I don't want to go Hellfire yeah not
that I'm saying go Hellfire like you
know certain things Etc but I don't wake
up saying I want to disobey my Lord I
came to this religion cuz I love this
religion and you guys know what I inshah
do for the insh is for the sake of Allah
yeah so this accusations no problem you
can throw at me but my guests especially
the sisters their honor is great in my
eyes and especially the woman and we
know one of the seven uh sins major sins
is what to dishonor talk about a sister
in a certain way so I have the I'm doing
this video to defend their honor and
also give some clarifications and before
I get into that I've been to the ca two
times in the past year Allah is my
witness I have made Dua you guys might
say this guy's out of his mind I don't
care I have made Dua for four projects
I'm working for marriage document
the bitter truth show another thing that
I'm working on and Salah Salam project
Salah plus where we teach new and born
Muslims how to pray Salah yeah in there
might be a link that you can donate yeah
so I made Dua why I said oh Allah make
these projects a for me now you're
thinking because you hold that opinion
that oh it's free mixing look at this
guy how could you ask for on something
that you committing a sin that is your
opinion which I'm going to come to we
have spoken to people of knowledge so
your opinion means zero to me whoever it
is even he's come out if he says he
believes is free mixing I respect your
opinion but that is your opinion she
with all du respect W I follow I
encourage people to follow you aldah
there's certain views that you have like
for example if a person misses Salah or
if a person doesn't pray Salah he's a
cfir that's your opinion I respect it
but I'm not going to come now and be
like your opinion is the opinion my dear
she may Allah bless you and preserve you
you give great benefit to the umah and I
always tell people to follow your uh uh
watch your videos however we have spoken
to far senior Scholars yes and I know
you're a high student of knowledge but
we speaking to people who were on the
level of an Alim and they have told us
this is not free mixing period and the
people I've spoken to in the back I
don't want to give names yeah because
people going to start attacking them
yeah I've spoken to they did not say to
his free miix and they said to me that
this show is two issues number
one makeup and I try my best not to look
to the opposite agenda so I don't know
who weing makeover I don't know my wife
is a co- producer she usually deals with
that so come and tell listen tell them
to you know if they're dressed up in a
certain way dressed like this if they're
wearing lipstick whatever take you off
yeah okay uh for that matter so in that
instance that was the case so to me I
know alhamdulillah in front of Allah I
will stand I know alhamdulillah it is
not free mixing the second thing was
sisters who don't wear the hijab who
wear hijab on the show cuz we control we
say look you want to come on you have to
you know the hair showing yes sister
Amir like we said before she was not a
hijab she became andam started wearing
the hijab after the show may Allah bless
her and her husband for having massive
contrib tions to the show so guys let's
come to this clip and watch it for
ourself and see what exactly was the
issue because I believe people
exaggerated it but I have to be just and
there's something that I'm going to in
talk about in a minute so let's watch it
here is the clip not satisfied in the
bedroom the wife does address it to the
husband that he will shame her he'll be
oh it's your fault you can't be
satisfied what I say is depend how you
approach it so if your woman goes to you
you don't perform properly that's going
to demasculate you but if she goes to
you that let's try something different
or the thing is you approach it in a way
that you don't attack the man you don't
attack the man but you can't approach in
a different way but if you go straight
at him of course he's going to so guys
that was the clip that you saw now if
you watch the entire video there is
context to it there is absolute context
to it and she is talking about a woman
we're talking about for example why do
women go down the level of being
disloyal to their husbands this is a
phenomena that is happening there are
women who are cheating on their husbands
or going down that route why do we
address these issues you might be shy
about it I am not because these issues
need to be discussed so there was a
context however I accept because there
there was some woman I was Anar woman
who came to the prophet mhammad to peace
be upon him about intimacy about
intimate stuff yeah okay now they came
to rep of peace be upon him to your guys
logic you can say oh well why is a non
Maham woman speaking yes that's the
message of Allah understandable and what
did the prophet peace upon him do he got
AA his wife to address the issue so this
is where I put my hands up and say the
following the scholars who gave us the
fatwa that it's not free mixing and
there is nothing wrong with the show and
we talking about issues pertaining to
what look let me read you some of this
stuff yeah do women do men want career
wives this is breaking down the family
unit okay sisters who want to be boss
babes or whatever this is destroying the
family unit which have a ripple effect
on the umah what did we discuss after
that can I Spy on my wife's phone yes
you should not spy on your wife's phone
we discussed that an important topic
that causes so many arguments in the
marital unit yeah should inls get
involved in marital disputes again one
of the biggest factors of marriages
divorce uh divorces happening and why
does her virginity matter for so many
men men they end marriages because of
this so we advise men how to deal with
it and we try to get the S to understand
the psychology of a man why you will you
marry a divorce again a big phenomena
big issue of divorce they come with
these baggage Etc we talk about this
phenomena why there's so many divorced
single mothers who are not married
there's this stigma on them yeah who
belongs in the kitchen another issue
which causes so many problems in the
marital unit why men get second wives
another big issue Subhan Allah which is
causing the breakdown of the family unit
real problems we're trying to deal with
real problems okay Ex-Wives using kids
Subhan Allah the biggest oppression
happening on men where they get divorce
and their wives do not allow them to see
the kids yes and this is a major sin to
break kinship yes there we go what do we
discuss we discuss all that should Mar
married couples have single friends IR
um irresponsible Instagram couples we're
given a false reality of what marriage
is yes uh uh we've done how to be a good
Muslim husband um you name it guys look
divorce pandemic okay um we've done
about good good bad and ugly side uh
side of dating apps okay these Muslim
apps okay and why wife is mother-in-law
big problem these are all things we
don't sit down with the sisters and chit
chat like oh yeah sister how you doing
we come and we have alhamdulillah like
we the fat we follow is what when we're
giving da in Speakers Corner to
non-muslim women three protocols we
follow from the scholars which is number
one it's what that it's in public number
two it's pertaining to Da number three
when the da is done you go your separate
ways those women we speak to who are
sometimes half naked we can't control
what they were in the bit truth show we
can so this whole issue of free mixing
this stand this is not even an issue for
me move it to this move it to the side I
just want to apologize and say yes when
it comes to the issue of ha this clip
should have not been there and I am
going to cut it inshah okay it should
have not been there okay why because at
the end of the day it's distasteful not
a matter of Haram it is distasteful okay
why even though she's talking about a
woman who's not satisfied and talking
about that why because the discussion is
what it can lead her to go down the
wrong path so it's us for us men to
understand and to cater to our wives
that's what the discussion was at hand
however that little clip on its own it's
distasteful so to me that's why I want
to apologize that
again it's a sensitive issue and I want
to say the scholars who have given us
the fat of the show are free from this
specific incident why because just
because they gave us a fatwa does not
mean that they condone every little
thing that happens there so this issue
like I said before it is distasteful a
nonaham two nonaham individuals speaking
about an issue even though it's
pertaining to something that is so
important maybe it is best that it
should have not been and I am very very
careful with this you've seen in many
episodes where there's specific thing I
want to talk about pertaining to
intimacy I hold back I go look there's
some sisters here I don't want to get
into detail we are very careful to that
so anyone that knows from the previous
episodes in many multiple occasions we
have said that even hijab you want to
mention something but because the
sisters are there we don't even get to
it because we know the elements and this
one it was a mistake we own up to it we
ask you guys uh myself to forgive me but
this honor of the sister who's talking
about this and the honor of the brother
should never be in question because we
were discussing a real important issue
the intentions were there for the Allah
to deal with this issue and that they
will benefit Muslim couples who are
watching this and anyone that watches
the B show knows alhamd will testify how
much it's benefited their marriages I've
got couples coming to me most of the
times when they see me that they watch
it with their partners and it has helped
them so for anyone other than that free
mixing this that no problem like I said
you before that is your opinion you want
to follow all day every alhamd I know I
am clear in front of Allah subh inshah
why because we are clearly it's not free
miix aldah to me it's the matter is
clear we have got a fatwa from my senior
senior schol
aldah I respect your opinion that is
your opinion may Allah bless and
preserve you that's all I wanted to say
in again please forgive me like I said
before it was distasteful and that clip
will be taken out and we'll be more
careful inah going forward but the show
as a whole aldah is a biggest a a big
blessing for the um inshallah and I urge
couples to watch it inshallah and you
can benefit we're not perfect but
inshallah the bitter truth show will
carry on brothers and sisters inshallah
with many more episodes where we're
dealing with the real issues that face
the family unit and caus the divorce rat
to happen and the breakdown of the
family unit inshallah that's all I
wanted to say inshallah uh and the way
the question was even asked to but again
like I said he holds a more staun uh
stricter opinion and I respect that
that's all I want to say brother and
sisters may Allah subh bless and
preserve you guys forgive us for our
shortcomings and just know W I genuinely
believe in this project wholeheartedly
my intentions is not I'm doing it for
this or for that Etc Allah subhana T
knows yeah other than that if you guys
want to carry on slandering and
dishonoring the guest Etc on it's I
should give you guys a gift on your good
deeds will be given to these individuals
because of your lack of knowledge of
speaking about a matter you don't know
and on if you run out of Good Deeds
you'll be carrying their sins is it
worth it I don't think it's so I'll
leave it to you guys inah till next time